okay let's get started
so hi everyone i'm michael stipe
i'm a microsoft mvp and i'm one of the
authors of the hot chocolate graphql
library.net
today i want to talk to you about
graphql schema stitching with
dotnet core or i would
rather say federated data graphs with
dotnet
i know that a lot of people in talks
every every time i go to conferences
that don't know what graphql is they
just
hear the term graph so let's introduce
a three minute do a three minute
introduction to graphql and then head
into the topic
so why is graphql so popular lately why
why does everybody want to build his own
data graph
create its own uh graphql server
so the reason for this is because
graphql
changed the predicament how we consume
data with traditional rest apis
or even grpc
api soap apis we always
have to take what the server tells us
that
there is so if a server offers a request
we have to swallow all the data that the
request offers to us
and just live with what the server
offers
with graphql this is fundamentally
different
like if we look at this simple graphql
query here
which fetches the currently looked in
user and from this currently logged in
user
just the name when we send such a
request to our server we get a response
back
that closely aligns our request
and that's one of the design goals with
graphql
it puts the consumer of the api in the
driver seat
and lets the consumer drive how the
interface between the server
and the client really looks like so if
we look at this response it almost
is as if the server just filled up our
request
graph with some data
but graphql doesn't stop there
so i cannot just build simple requests
and as my um as
my demands change i can change my
request
add more add more to my request that i
want to consume
like for instance i want to drill into
the profile picture
and get details over the profile picture
of the user that is logged in
and i can send that again to my graphql
server
and as we expect expect the graphql will
just fill that up with
some data
and as we now can already reason about
it's not all about simple simple spa
spheres
or simple requests where i just can say
give me this and that field it's just
really about data graphs
where i can drill into the relations
of my nodes like for instance i could
drill into the friends of the currently
locked in user
and ask for the name and last theme of
the sign in user and of its friends
and as i expect i get the data back also
for this
in the shape i expected but if we look
closer here we can see that we already
introduced some repetition
into our graphql query name in last
scene
is declared two times and there is a
construct
in graphql called fragment
which is our primitive for composition
and
with that we can build fragment
hierarchies as we
create component hierarchies
in our ui or class hierarchies
in our backends
so with graphql i have a single endpoint
since i'm designing the requests or i
design what
data i want to consume so i can issue
that to one
endpoint that makes it that simple to
use
and with graphql i can consume all the
data that i need
at a given moment in time or that i need
in
a specific component with one request
and that completely gets rid of the
overall under fetching problem
and graphql is built on a strong type
system
and that gives me cons confidence when i
consume data
since the graphql execution engine will
enforce
that the data abides to the declaration
that we did in our type system
and this is different to things like
swagger where the
schema essentially can get out of bounds
with the
implementation and that makes graphql
super predictable to use
okay so with graphql i aim
for this big data graph
for this i would say monolith in which
i can really reason about data drill
into data ask for everything i want
so ideally when we build graphql we just
put a thin layer
of graphql over our business layer
and graphql is a really great way to
expose
or give access to our business layer
it essentially lets us create this
ubiquitous
data graph
where we uh can explore our business
layer in a much
better way than with traditional
technologies like
um rest where i always have to
simplify my data put it in serializable
objects so when we start with graphql
apis we often
start by creating our model
that we want to consume an
interconnected graph
every for instance would build a webshop
we could start like this where we create
a user
that user is connected with the reviews
that this user writes i can drill into
that
and the review for instance is connected
with the user so i can drill from both
sides
and also we have the product that is in
the center
and where we can also drive into the
reviews that somebody wrote about this
product
this is great it really lets us
drive and define our graph in a really
rich way with rich types
and from a query standpoint from a
consumer standpoint this is really great
because the front-end developer or the
consumer of the api
in general can just drill into the data
for instance from the currently logged
in user
you can drill into the reviews that this
user has written and from there into the
product about
which this user has written reviews
and also as i said we can explore this
from the other side by um
for for instance asking for the top
products
of the web shop and then expo
exploring if these these top products
are available what the shipping
estimates are
and then drilling into the reviews and
the author who wrote the reviews this is
great from a consumer standpoint
but as our graph grows and introduces
more and more types
it becomes cumbersome to have just a
monolith
often graphql is used then over
a set of domain services i'm not
speaking of microservices here
since usually you aim to have domain
services down there
and these domain services now can be
developed
by different teams that
work in their silo with their domain
expertise
and push this server forward but the
problem that now arises
is that if i divide that up into
those silo services domain services
i always have to advance this domain
service and
the graphql layer as way as well
and that means every time i change for
instance the account service i have to
change the
graphql servers and this introduces
new problems with working together as
teams
because now i always have a lock
when somebody is changing something in
the graph
and i have to wait for the changes to
commence
so ideally we would like to have these
silos where we for instance in the
account service just have the user just
have to
have to care about the data of the user
in this instance we have just the name
of the user
and in the product service we might just
want to have a catalog of products and
which essentially consists of the name
and the price
and then we might have a fourth a third
service the inventory service
that keeps track of what we have in
stock
and what the shipping estimates are
and ideally these services could also
provide some
configuration to our overall graph to
tell the overall graph
how these types really interconnect
ideally our account service could just
tell the overall graph that this user is
essentially the author in the reviews
and in such a scenario
we would like just to have one
technology
just graphql where the overall graph can
delegate
the query parts that concern one domain
service to that domain service and on
the
other side i want to drive this graph
from the bottom from the
from the domain services and build out
the types in my domain services and then
create a bigger and bigger data graph
for my company so the solution to that
is graph distribution and we have a
couple of
approaches here so there is schema
stitching
which is a centralized approach where
the gateway
essentially has all the stitching logic
and knows how to combine these graphs
i would end up with the same problem i
introduced
with having these domain services down
there where i always have to advance my
um my domain service and the overall
graph at once
and create those locking scenarios but
then there is
schema federation which essentially
defines that the domain services by
themselves can build up that
top level graph both
terms were coined actually by apollo but
uh they there are a lot of flavors
around in the grafton
hemisphere what i'm showing you today is
how you can do that with
dot net core and hot chocolate
and i would say let's just dive in and
look how we could build up such a
distributed graph
okay so i prepared a little demo
let me just pull that up and
let me just compile that so that visual
studio code knows my types
and i walk you through a bit so
essentially i have built
uh four graphical services here accounts
inventory products and reviews
and each of these provides different
aspects to my overall graphs that we
want to create
so if we look at the accounts graph it's
a simple graphql
server let me put that
site it's a simple graphql server that
has a simple query type that provides us
with um with a
field to fetch all users or a field to
fetch a single user
the user is also simple provides just
name
birth date and username so just a couple
of data about the
user and then i have like the review
service
that provides me with uh essentially the
review
and the revenue service knows some ids
about the
the author who wrote that and these
really interconnect with my
accounts data but each of these services
owns their data silos so they own the
data that they
provide so in order to interconnect
these um these domain graphs
i need to have something called a
gateway a graphql
gateway and for that we just
need to create a simple.net project so
dotnet new web and we call it
a gateway
and just let's add it to the solution
so that i can compile
just reload so visual studio
gets it that there is a new project so
the gateway is a
very simple
asp.net core application it doesn't have
anything in there so the first thing to
use
schema federated schema stitching is
essentially to add some graphical
to it so let's put the hot chocolate a
speedo encore package in here
and then we also need
a package that lets us um do all this d
schema stitching magic
and that is the hot chocolate
stitching package and in this
we are using a federated approach that
means we want to have it more robust and
we need
some kind of an instance that lets
us push messages between those services
and also store the configuration and for
that we are using redis
there are other things that you could
use and you could even use a pull
approach
but with resist you have really a hot
reload approach with your schema
so before we head into really
all this setup here we also are using a
tie here
that means and to not always start all
the services i just put that in a tie
configuration
and let me just also
put in here the
gateway configuration so that everything
compiles
so the nice thing with type is that i
now just can
do tools to
restore and then
add type run
watch and now we can work on our gateway
our microservices here
and i will automatically restart the
part
that we are changing and also tai will
distribute
as a redis cache and stuff like that and
keep everything
running it's a great way to also debug
those federated
federated data graphs on your local
machine
okay so let's get into it so the first
thing is we want to set up a
a gateway a graphql gateway
so we are going into our gateway
solution going into startup
cs and we need to set
up a simple graphql server here so we
would
normally start with services
dot and graphql server
and then maybe we want to have a simple
query type
in there and since this is a gateway we
just provide an empty
query type since we will fill it up from
the
domain services so we just give it a
name
called a query and we leave it like that
so this is a graphql server it's not a
valid graph credit server so it would
fail when we call it
but is it it's a graphql server and
then we essentially map graphql
as an endpoint and with that we could
execute graphql credits
but in order to push configurations to
this graphql server
we now need to connect it to redis so
let's put in the redis connection
to our dependency injection
and then import the remote
schemas so the schema set we are pushing
to it
from our redis and we are giving it the
the configuration name demo so that is
our essentially our name or
configuration name
and with that essentially the gateway is
almost configured the one thing that we
are missing
is the connections to our downstream
services
and for this we are just using the http
connection
uh http client factory sorry
so i'm adding here four fixed http
clients that can
that represent all the downstream
services
the cool thing here is you could also
implement that on your in a more dynamic
way where you
also get from it is the configurations
and the cool thing with uh
http client factory in general you can
make it very robust by using
poly or some other tooling
okay so the gateway is now ready
let's push some configurations so let's
start with our account service
in our account service we have
fundamentally
a simple data graph we already explored
that
let me have a look at how this um
data graph for accounts looks like at
the moment
we're opening this graphql server
let's just have a look at the schema
at the moment we just have two fields
here on the query type
so we could as we already saw in the
code
fetch all users
or fetch a specific user
awesome that works this is a simple
server that we have down there but what
i saw what we saw in the slides
i had this nice schema with me where i
could drill in
that is actually what we want to have on
our
gateway on our overall company data
graph
so let's get into our configuration here
and first put in redis so that we can
push our configurations from from our
domain servers
up to the um to the gateway
the next thing we need to to do
is to publish our schema configuration
so essentially what we are publishing
here
under the name accounts to the overall
stitching configuration demo our schema
but we also can modify our schema we
rewrite our schema so for instance we
are ignoring all the root types so we
are ignoring
users and we are ignoring the other user
field
what we really want to do is we rewrite
our data graph
and this we can do with graphql sdn so
we can put in a stitching
dot graphql here
and then we can extend the query type
that we have in our gateway
in this instance i'm i'm introducing a
new field that is called me
and is from the type user that i have
here my downstream service
and i can call that by calling the user
field on my service and providing an id
in this instance i'm taking a static id
usually with authentication i would take
that from the
from the context okay
so let's just add the type extension
here
the file and with that already our data
graph should work
let's go to our gateway which is on
port 5050.
okay it's loading and we already can see
that we now have a me field here
there's nothing else to it so we could
essentially now
um already query our
are currently locked in user okay but
that is
um just a simple thing to do
and we really want to interconnect the
data graphs
so the next thing really would be to go
to the review service
go to the startup cs
and also connect that to our data graph
so again we add redis
and then publish also our configuration
of this service
to our gateway
and again we are ignoring all the root
types because
these are more meant for the domain
service we want to rewrite the
configuration here
to integrate with our types that we have
on the gateway
so stitching dot graphql again
you can name it however you want so it
doesn't isn't fixed to that
name so in this in this instance we are
extending the user
and we are introducing a reviews field
here
and here you can actually see we are
taking out of the context from the
original
entity the id
and try to and resolve with that
id the reviews that belong to that user
okay this is already working again like
i said
with um with redis and
and ty this is really hot reload so we
can just
refresh go in here and we can already
see that our reviews type is stitched in
and we can now really
drill into that the good thing is that
the graphical query engine will figure
out query plans
to query that effectively it also knows
about overlapping data data that you
have in both services
and we also try to reduce the service
that we involve when we are resolving
the data
okay but let's go on with that because
review
also actually should expose the user
that that means we could go back to our
account service here and essentially
extend
the review type with the user
again
again we are taking the author id from
the
review type and resolving with that
the awesome and again this is already
hot reloaded the schema already
has this capability as author
and we can drill further into the data
okay but now let's really interconnect
the product service make that
shine and also connect that with the
inventory and the inventory is quite
another thing
so we again go to our service
configuration from the product service
now
again we add redis this becomes now
muscle memory
we are just adding these things
we are publishing the products details
and also with products we are
introducing a stitching dot
graphql
and products is also reachable from the
query type so let's also introduce
a new top level field to our query type
this is top products we can uh get the
top products and provide an integer how
many top products we want
in this instance i can just delegate
without any information because the same
field exists on my on my
domain graph and then we can
extend the review with the product and
in this case
we need some context information that we
get here
by using this context variable
which we then delegate to our
local domain service okay
this is already reloaded
and we now can be drilled into our top
products here
take the first two maybe and
drill into the data that we have
so while there is no interconnection yet
we already can
drill into the product from the review
you can see we just need to define how
the edges connect
and then the data is already exposed
okay last but not least let's um
let's put in the the
inventory and then i
show you something different
so again we put in redis
and again we publish our data graph
and again we also add the stitching
dot graphql to our sub to our
domain service and we
extend the product with the inventory
and in this service it's different
because the data shapes completely are
different
and i don't want them so in this
instance
i for i drill into the inventory info
and just pick a certain field i also
could aggregate if that would be a list
i could still drill in and aggregate so
this passive text is very
very powerful and also i have here a
shipping estimate algorithm that i will
use
and this is also just a scalar so i'm
creating here two new fields
and are just using some some
functionality of the server not
all of it like i did with the all the
others where
always integrated the full type
and that should already be
available i have it in stock info and i
can get the shipping estimate
the last thing we really need to put in
here
is um ah there's one error i just saw
i just messed this up
the snippet tool
always swallows my dollar signs here
okay so that is in let's just verify
that it works
no it doesn't
products let's take these guys out
that works in stock
that
does it work now yeah now it works
and this shipping estimate
ah okay it's a shipping estimate that
makes the problem let's have a look
what it actually is dollar price
dollar field actually looks good
okay
shipping estimate okay i don't know what
i messed up with this field
doesn't matter it usually works
okay let's go to the review service and
integrate here the
the rest of it
and that essentially is extending the
product types
with the reviews so now
now my product will essentially have a
list of reviews to that product
and this lets me really now also
drill into my a graph my data graph
from the product side so i can
drill now in here reviews
i can go in the author of the review get
the name
here and also from the reviews
get the body
try and run that look at the result a
bit
and i can see here that i have a table
that is in stock and i'm drilling in
and pulling up the review body here
edda lovelace loved it so it works
so this is a pretty easy to build up
your graph
and this essentially lets you really
drive
all this from the domain services you
don't have to
wait for one another to deploy a new
gateway
because you can do everything from the
downstream services
so there is another thing here because
sometimes you want to mix approaches
and while we use now a federated
stitching approach here
sometimes you really want to add some
some logic to the gateway maybe you have
a very static logic that
does some some things integrate some
data modify some data
since this gateway essentially is a
simple graphql server you can also
really put here everything in that you
would in this demographical server
so i could also just create here maybe
a code first type extension
like let's call it queries
and this varies type
extends
an object type
in this case we are extending queries
and even brings in its own type let's
call it maybe the address
and we just give it a street
and maybe we are um we are
letting people ask for the address of
the company or
something like this so we just say
address
get address
and then we return our address object
here
which says subscript
so this is now in our gateway and we can
now just say uh add type extension
and instead of using the graphql syntax
we are now using
these nice c sharp types that already
bring their resolvers with them
and this is not queries this is krabby
sorry
and already our system should have
be reloaded we can see we have here now
a field
address and um i could ask for that
and already have this object in here
and can see that that really also
integrates in our data graph
but the really cool thing is that we
also could interconnect these things
like we could interconnect that with the
data that comes from the downstream
services that i don't even know that
the downstream stream service is pushing
up to us
so we could introduce
another extension that
is our user so we call it even user
and we just say this user essentially
has an address
i know it's the same address over and
over again we could also
just uh inject here
uh the user id and then
transfer transform this address and
really look it up
but demo purposes let's just
keep that simple so we have extending
the user
and that's a central approach i would
say
where we just say add
type extension then put in the user
and again this is a type extension this
is actually not the user that is just
the user in our context
but it extends the user of the overall
graph
so our graph should already have
reloaded
and we should be able now to sit here in
our user
and ask for the user's address
and that's just in there address does
not exist
on the type user okay
that i messed up was totally improvised
but essentially this would work
under normal conditions i don't know why
it
delegated this yet
okay but essentially you can drive the
graph from
two directions you can either use the
central approach to
advance your graph or you can change it
from the
from the domain servers and this means
that now i'm really able to change
things in my accounts graph like go
in here and maybe also introduce from
the bottom up
changes to my to my system
for instance i could remove the username
and
we say okay name is enough we don't need
that username
and and then just get
rid of this here
and have a look at my overall graph
again
where at the moment we still can see the
username
and when we refresh we can see it's gone
so now that the team that is owning the
account service is totally
enabled to just push their changes to
push
their graph and don't
always be blocked by the other teams
there's one more aspect i want to
highlight here
and that's why we also introduce that
whole thing with redis that we
allow the configurations to be stored
there is a federated approach where you
essentially
pull in the changes from your downstream
servers
so the gateway would occasionally pull
and refresh the schemas that are
that are now in refresh downstream
services
um but this always introduces the
problem that the
gateway would need to stitch
every now and then with the
redis approach we essentially push
the schema configurations to the redis
and then do in the background
uh the schema stitching and store the
stitched schema on the redis
meaning that if any service in our
federation would go down has an error
the overall graph wouldn't be affected
let me demonstrate that
go back to our solution go back to our
project here
and introduce a change
that essentially breaks our
graph foil for a minute so we go to our
user
and this time we are reintroducing the
username
and this will now yield in a compile
error
so we can see this doesn't really
work anymore and that means
we our thai orchestrator cannot
get this machine up anymore and that's
actually exactly what i want here
since now if i execute against that i
can see there
are errors against the the data graph
but actually there are only errors
to the data portion that works
with the user
so if i for instance just get the
products i don't have any problem
and i also have no problem if i fetch
the author here
want the name i get an error
that's that's true but graphql is
actually very good at working with
partial data so graphql it doesn't just
fail uh graphql will still give you the
data that is valid
and just um return now for the also
because the author in this instance was
nullable
that means i still can use all the
products data
and and my
my whole data graph doesn't go down just
because
some developer made a change that really
affected my overall graph
um that can also be combined with things
like kubernetes where you first
try to stitch try to stitch try to push
the new configuration to
redis and then if we cannot stitch that
this is uh um this will lead to enhanced
uh health check problem so you can
implement the health check there
and then docker will kubernetes will
just
roll back your container and your old
graph will be
fully intact but even if there
are things like the databases down from
one of the microservice
services or domain services you will
still be able
to consume most of the data that you
have in your data graph
and i think that is from a resilience
perspective
really a nice thing
so let's put back the data graph in
order
save that we are redeploying the whole
thing
and now we can put
we have an intact graph again
okay back to my slides
we have a couple of minutes for
questions in a minute
so we built a distributed graph with
graphql
we saw that it's actually not so
difficult and really enables
really enables you to iterate faster
with federated graphs in graphql
you are more flexible it adds complexity
especially you have to think about
things like roll backing your container
and stuff like that
but it adds more flexible flexibility
when you are spreading out your team
when your data graph grows when more
teams are involved
i would definitely always tell people
to first start without
without schema stitching or without
federated graphs just build
a single monolith at the beginning
because it's super easy
and then spread out the work and that is
actually really simple to do you can
even
first start doing local schema stitching
where you start to create multiple
schemas within one service and spread
them
out slowly and then when you're ready
you move them into a separate service
so there's actually no reason to
immediately start with schema stitching
but it is something that you should
consider when your data graph
grows and grows and you are suddenly
having problems to deploy the whole
thing because you always have to
deploy everything um
there are multiple approaches to these
kinds of um
distributed graphs as we saw in schema
stitching where we can
do a central approach and there's also
the approach where you
push data in a federated
setup yeah you can deploy faster and you
can
deploy more easily with this setup since
you essentially can push micro changes
to your domain services and
swap out just uh small units of your
of your graph it also divides the graph
in logical
concerns like the account inventory
checks and stuff like that
if you want to try it out get to our
github repository
or head over to our website
at chulukim.com and if you have
questions i would be open to
answer questions now
um i've got a question it's not related
to the talk exactly but i saw you using
project thai
and yes one of the new things in dotnet
5 is that when you're
when you're using.net watch and the
application changes your browser is
refreshed as well
does this work with project tai uh
not not really no that's that it's not
tight
so i was wondering yeah it is super fast
it just
uh switches out the parts that you need
to reload
i really like it um for demos and also
for
working locally it's not saying i mean
when you
publish your stuff you use things like
cubic meters but this is
always a pain to set up in the thai
configuration actually
you can put everything together
uh like i have here the redis container
that i used
and this is just being pulled down from
docker hub
and then i have my projects and
everything is
set up nicely so it's really a nice
thing
and one cool thing i don't know
i don't know if you have seen that
you can go here on the thai dashboard
and then you have essentially an
overview over your services that are
running
cool you can see that here is the
container and stuff so there's always a
management instance
and you even can intercept the uh
intercept the calls between the
containers and stuff
so that that is an option that you have
to configure
but then um thai will issue like
site containers to intercept
the communication between all this stuff
and that is really
great to debug so i love this this thing
yeah that's awesome stuff i have to try
it thanks yeah
okay if you also have questions
afterwards you just can
give me a message um is the um
project up in like github or is it
on your website you mean uh
the the hot chocolate project is what
you've just been using yes
uh you mean time you mean the
the the um the main talk
ah okay just making sure yeah
here's how chocolate the whole code is
here is open source
it's um and the mit license
so a fork it have fun with it
use it or give us a star if you liked it
we always appreciate that there are more
tools to that we
we not only have schema stitching
graphql server
or we also have a graphqlclient4.net
that is fully typed and we are one of
the fastest graphql servers that are out
there
we just released version 11.
if somebody is interested and
rafael we are at the moment
at the moment it always changes because
as soon as you put out benchmarks
somebody else will try to
beat you always away
thanks thanks for talking it's really
been helpful
you're welcome
good uh i will be available on
this lecture so you can also shoot me a
message
and i will be sure to answer uh sorry
one quick question
before you showed um you know during the
process
well i presume it is but uh can you i
mean
you need the example for example yeah
um it is uh i have
there are examples but this with high i
haven't uh pushed to
our example repository so usually the
examples are here
but i always put my
public speaking demos up
and essentially you can go to my repo
michael style public speaking
and then you can look nfc london
and then the whole demo is here
there it is there there is actually a
better way i'm just we have this
workshop repository
which has a guided walkthrough to all
graphql
and if you here go on version two you
also have a scripted version
of all the schema stitching variants
like
uh the schema federation with hot
chocolate
and there is even the scripted version
that you can
try out yourself to build that up
all right that's great thank you i can
close
that post that to the slack channel
and then you can find the link
that also has all the nice thai magic in
it
you